χειρηματική τη επαγγελματική και τα λοιπά όμως πάντα είχα αυτή την εμπλωκή με τον δρόπο
που σοεξίεσα αι θεωρώ ότι τούτον εδα το έναςμα όταν μου εζήτηθηκε κάποια στιγμή ν
αναλάβω στη ταπρόεδρο τη σητατοπσανα απεδέκτηκα δεν το επαιδιοξα ήταν όμως μια περίοδος επαγγελματική που
έκανενα ένα τραντζήσω μια αλλαγή η οποία θα παίρνα και χρόνο καα σκεφτικα ότε ντα
ξεέχωη κι χρόνια μοστά υ τούτη θέση εθκιομισή χρόνια γιατί γιατί ωή κάπωσέ στη συνέχεια
ο φίλω να σου κόφυσικά ότι ποτέ δεν οιμόν μέσα σε ωμάδες στο δημοκρατηο σαμό
που επιάσαν από την οικογένεια μου έτσι ούτε προσπάθησα επαιδίο ξπότέ να πιάσω ποιατ δήποτε
όφελος που τον πατέρα μου τη θείαμου τις ζέτα η οποίον τίποτε άλλιον εμπλέα για
τω τότε η πολιτική μου φίλιε μέναανεξάρτητι που τους ανθρώπους είναιαιανθρώποι που γνώρισα ότανιο μορών
μετά ανθρώπο υπουγνώρισα στες πουδές μας μετά ανθρωπ υπογνώρισα στη κοινωνία στσπγγελματικό ς βγείο και
τα λιβά η πολιτική μου φίλη να το πούμεέτσι στο στο κόμμα ούτε ν πρόεδρο
ούτε με τον πρώτρό ανα στασιάδην είχα κάποια σχέσι ούτε με τον προεδρο ναβέρο είχα
κάποια σχέση όταν ακόμα και μου ζητήθηκε να πόστησίδα νομίζω είναι προήλθε ακριβώς που τούτα
τα κέντρα που κάποιους άλληλος μέσα στο κόμμα που έριξαν τονομα μουούτε τώρα η πρόεδρος
ήταν πολιτική μου ίλη γνωστώ νομίζω ότι εγώ εψημίσα δημετ δημετρίου εσοκομματικά τον οποίο εγνώρισα
πολιτικά δεν και ξέρα τοκοπεδο γνώρισα πολιτικάστο ναλάι το μιχάιόπο κλαίο σας αποδέχθηκεουκάσουλίδηση γνώαποτετες μια
θέση που συηείτε έτώνα γιατί δεν υπήρχε